This program is for educational purposes
only. The content is not intended to
[music] diagnose, treat, cure, or
prevent any diseases, nor is it intended
to take the place of your primary care
physician. Statements in this program
have not been evaluated by the FDA. As
an empowered individual, you do have
options available. We're honored to
continue and share the teachings of the
founding father of science of
epigenetics, Dr. Joel Wallik.
This program is for educational purposes
only. The content is not intended to
diagnose, [music] treat, cure, or
prevent any diseases, nor is it intended
to take the place of your primary care
physician. Statements in this program
have not been evaluated by the FDA. As
an empowered individual, you do have
options. available. We're honored to
continue and share the teachings of the
founding father of science of
epigenetics, Dr. Joel Wallik.
This program is for educational purposes
only. The content is not intended to
[music] diagnose, treat, cure, or
prevent any diseases, nor is it intended
to take the place of your primary care
physician. Statements in this program
have not been evaluated by the FDA.
[music] As an empowered individual, you
do have options available. We're honored
to continue and share the teachings of
the founding father of science of
epigenetics, Dr. Joel Wallik.
Hello. Hello everybody. Let's go ahead
and open up that Zoom room and welcome
and welcome to Daily with Doc and Becca.
My name is Becca Jukes. We are excited
to have you here with us investing in
yourself.
Well, when you invest time, you know,
time is worth money. So, we want to make
sure that we give you actual information
that you can use in your life to help
yourself have the best health possible.
And I can't think of a better person to
help me do that than my friend
pharmacist Ben Fuches. Now, pharmacist
Ben is absolutely fantastic. He has been
in the pharmaceutical world. He's been
in the skin world. He's been in the
neutrautical world. and he loves science
and breaking things down and letting us
know how things work in a way that we
without a totally scientific mind for
many of us can be can understand. So,
pharmacist Ben, thank you so much for
joining us today. How's 2026 going for
you?
>> Oh, it's amazing. This is this is
starting to be the most amazing year
ever. I can't believe it. I think it's
crazy. I mean, I know it's only the
second day, but I think this is going to
be an absolutely spectacular year. And
you know, you you cracked me up when you
said uh when you said science. There
used to be a show called Dr. Science.
You ever hear about this? And they go,
he's not a real doctor. He has a
bachelor's degree in science. I was that
that kind of reminded me of that. No, I
just like what is science anyway? What
What do you mean by science?
>> I like biology. I like nutrition. I like
chemistry. I have a I like chemistry as
well.
>> Science.
>> Yeah, it's a type of science, but
everything's kind of scientific. The
scientific method is where you
hypothesize, test, you get results, and
then you feed it back in and do another
hypothesis, and you test and feed it
back in and do another hypothesis.
That's a scientific method as opposed to
superstition where you just have these
vague beliefs. So, uh, yeah, AJ says,
"Dr. Science, did you ever hear that
show Dr. Science?" He's not a real
doctor. He has a bachelor's degree in
science. Anyway, so I like chemistry and
really it's kind of I kind of take
advantage of it a little bit because
nobody likes chemistry. So I get to be
the guy who likes who works with
chemistry. And if you know chemistry,
you can do herbs, you can understand
herbs, you can understand nutrition, you
can understand pharmacy, you can
understand cooking, you can understand
relationships, just people talking to
each other is chemistry. Haven't you
ever said, "Oh, that's good chemistry."
Chemistry is just how things go together
and everything in life goes together
with things. And so if you understand
chemistry, you can be really good at
life. So I think chemistry is the most
important thing to understand. And I get
to take advantage of the fact I happen
to love it. Really love it. Like I read
it when I'm bored. I read chemistry,
chemistry books and chemistry papers.
>> Another science that I absolutely love.
>> What's that?
>> And that's the science that gave me
hope. There's another science that I
love and that's epigenetics.
>> Yeah, epigenetics is very cool too. And
and the thing about understanding these
kinds of things is it it takes you away
from being manipulated by jargon. It pro
it protects you from being manipulated
by jargon. And unfortunately in the
world of you know there's this kind of
un
awkward relationship between marketing
and health you know and and we're here
to we have to do marketing but we also
have to do health. And you got to be
really careful that you that you don't
get into too much jargon. And that's the
problem. That's what I like that's why I
consider myself what we do on this
program to be so important is because we
kind of dissolve jargon and get to the
real real uh chemistry that's real
science that's underneath it. And that's
kind of what we you know we do every we
do pretty much on every program. And I
think I do it every time I do a podcast
or I do an interview is I'm really
trying to get down underneath what most
people hear in the world of marketing or
commercials or advertising or promotion
and get into the real technology of it,
the real science of it. And I think
people appreciate that too.
>> Oh, I totally I personally do. That's
for sure. Totally. And I know I'm not
the only one. Now, pharmacist Ben, there
there's one thing that you have really
had a passion for and that has to do
with skin.
So, let's take to the time to talk about
collagen.
>> Collagen,
>> how it affects our skin and I mean I
mean it affects the skin, the joints,
the gut.
>> No, it affects everything. Your whole
body is strong.
>> Yeah. Your cola means glue in Latin.
Collagen is the glue that holds the body
together. Some 30% or so of the protein
in the body is collagen. Collagen is
probably the most abundant protein on
the planet. It's and when we think of
collagen, we think of like holding
everything together. But collagen also
has electrical properties that are
really interesting. And in fact, as
collagen deteriorates, our body's
electricity deteriorates and our
coherence deteriorates. Coherence is a
really interesting word that you're
going to start to hear more and more
about. And I I absolutely love this
word. and coherence. The word coherence
is sits at the interface between physics
and chemistry. Chemistry only works
because of physics. And if you think
chemistry is overwhelming, physics, and
when I say physics, I mean quantum
physics, not mechanical physics
necessarily, but quantum physics. That's
like off the charts overwhelming. And
coherence sits at the juncture of
chemistry and and uh and quantum physics
in the sense that when we are healthy
physically physiologically healthy we're
coherent
meaning our body's electrical nature is
all going in the same direction.
Coherence can be thought of like an
orchestra by thinking of an orchestra.
Do you ever go to the symphony? At the
beginning of the symphony, they're all
tuning up and it's all cacophinous and
it's all noisy and then they start
playing
>> and it's beautiful music,
>> right?
>> I was in the symphonic band. I
absolutely
>> You know what I'm talking about. Yeah.
What did you play? What do you play? I
didn't realize that.
>> I played the saxophone. Alto saxophone
in this band.
>> I did not know that. That's really
interesting. Awesome. Um I love the
saxophone. So then you know what I'm
talking about. At the beginning they're
all tuning up and it's all noisy and
then all of a sudden they start playing
uh and it's beautiful. What's the
difference? When they're tuning up,
they're incoherent. And when they're
playing music, the the music is in or
the noise, the sound is incoherent. And
then when they're playing their music,
the sound is coherent. Coherence gives
functionality. And we from a musical
standpoint, we interpret functionality
as beauty. And there there is actually
an interesting relationship between
functionality and beauty. But that's for
another that's another story. Point I
want to make is it's about coherence.
Aging uh uh youthfulness is coherent.
Aging is incoherent. Health is coherent.
Disease is incoherent. When when our
body breaks down and all the things we
hate about our bodies breaking down are
all the end result of our body's
electrical energy, quantum energy
in becoming incoherent.
So what does that this have to do with
collagen? Collagen is a coherence
mechanism.
It has electrical properties that allow
uh that allow electrical energy
particularly electrical energy in water
to become coherent and that improves our
body's physiology, functionality and
ultimately our health and our beauty. So
in addition to being structurally
important it's also important for
electricity and by electricity I'm
talking about by supporting coherence by
supporting the coherent nu electrical
coherence in the body quantum and when
we say electrical it's really quantum so
we'll just we'll call it electricity so
all the electricity becomes coherent
just like in a symphony when we have
enough collagen our collagen breaks down
we lose coherence you know what that
looks like physiologically to the eye
when we lose coherence it looks like
blobification what I call blobification,
right? You know, and I like that word
and I know, you know, it sounds
interesting, right? But that's basically
what happens as we age. We blobify, you
know, we we go from having lean uh lean
angles uh to softer angles and and
people freak out and the medical model
has strategies for that. They'll they'll
surgically
try to duplicate coherence. This is what
medicine does. This why I always tease
and I make a joke about doctoring.
Doctrine is to commit a fraud. And by
that I mean doctoring ma uh has the
tools to make it look like we're
healthy. That's what a facelift does for
example. Facelift makes your skin look
youthful. It's not really youthful. It
just gives the appearance of being
youthful mechanically.
But by building collagen or if you can
figure out a way to prevent the
degradation of collagen as we age, you
can have real a re a natural facelift
that will look real. And that's really
what the difference in a nutshell, one
of the differences, one of the main
differences between what we talk about
in this program and modern medicine.
Medicine fabricates and synthesizes
beauty. What we're doing is we're
stimulating. We're medicine stimulates.
We stimulate.
Collagen is important for the structure
of the body and for uh improving
electrical coherence in the body. We
lose our collagen, fall apart
structurally and we lose coherence. So,
building collagen is the very essence of
anti-aging. Now, you may have recall,
excuse just a second here. You may
recall, I've said before, building
connective tissue is the very essence of
anti-aging.
I hope that's not too gross to drink out
of the bottle like that. Um,
>> your bottle.
>> It's my bottle. I know. I had some guy
freak out when I did it in the middle of
a talk once. So, I became
self-conscious. Anyway, um, uh, I've
said before the connective tissue is the
very essence of anti- building
connective tissue is the very essence of
anti-aging. And I said building collagen
is the very essence of anti-aging. So,
what's that distinction? How do you how
do you uh jive those two ideas? Collagen
is the main protein in connective
tissue. Connective tissue is made up of
collagen and goo. When I say goo, I'm
talking about slime. I call it goo. It's
really uh polysaccharides and
proteoglyolic sugars and protein sugar
complexes. Okay, that's what makes the
combination of protein. I call it goo.
I'll tell you why I call it goo here in
a second. Uh the combination of protein
of protein
sugar complexes. They're called
proteoglycans.
I hesitate to use that word because it's
such a awkward word, but that's what it
is. Proteoglycan
meaning proteins and sugars. the protein
sugar complexes and polysaccharides
long chains of sugar. Most famous one
for us is fuccoidin.
So polysaccharides are long long chains
of sugar and proteoglycans are sugar
protein complexes. Together they form
the goo
um gives connective tissue its kind of
um hydrated properties. It's slimy
properties and connective tissue does
have a slimy quality. The collagen acts
like fibers in the goo.
Now, I'm not a big construction guy or
or concrete guy, but as I understand it,
concrete is made up of sometimes of of
steel with particles inside. Is that
concrete or that cement? I always get
the let's get those mixed up.
>> You know, concrete. So, concrete.
>> Yeah, concrete.
>> And has these they call is that what
they call rebar, I think. Right.
>> We got the rebar for structure.
>> Rebar for structure. Right. And the
combination of the rebar plus the
particles in the in the uh concrete give
the concrete a certain flexibility and
hardness. You want to say something?
>> Well, concrete actually has rocks mixed
in with it also.
>> Yeah. To give it hard.
>> Cement is the base.
>> Got it. Okay. Got it. Got it. Got it.
Okay. So, so does cement have rebar in
it too? Steel rebar?
>> It can depending on what you're using it
for.
>> Okay. So what's the purpose of having
steel plus plus plus goo basically hard
goo is it gives it flexibility that it
wouldn't have otherwise that's what the
connective tissue is the connective
tissue is a combination of the collagen
and I call it goo but it's proteoglycan
and polysaccharides the reason I call it
goo is because it interacts with water
very effectively to form slime
and and that's basically the the the
texture of what's called the uh the
connective tissue aside from the
collagen which does which is not slimy.
That's more like a steel rebar. And it's
this combination that gives the body its
structure and form. Much more than that,
but it also gives the body its structure
and form. Now, I call it tissue, but and
that again that's kind of biological,
but you want to think of it. I to
simplify just call it stuff. The body's
made up of four kinds of stuff. Okay?
Tissue if you will. It has a core and
then it has stuff around it. Tissue
around it. And then it's electrified. So
you got the core and then the stuff
around it is called epithelia or
epithelial tissue sometimes people say
uh and then the whole thing is
electrified with nervous tissue. It's
the core that is the bulk of our bodies.
80% or so 90% even is the core all
covered and electrified. Make sense? I
call the core the flesh robot. We've
talked about this before. And the flesh
robot is the stuff you see at the bodies
exhibit. If you go to the museum, you
know, you you know what I'm talking
about. The bodies exhibit where they
show you what the body looks like
without skin uh and without neurology,
without nervous tissue. It's the core,
the flesh robot. That's most of our
bodies. That flesh robot in turn is made
up of two other types of stuff. And
those two types of stuff are wound
together. So they're they're intimately
connected with each other. And those two
types of stuff are called muscle tissue
and connective tissue. And those are the
four types of stuff. You got the flesh
robot made of muscle tissue and
connective tissue and you've got um the
the whole flesh robot coated with
epithelial tissue and electrified with
nervous tissue. And those are the four
types of tissue. The four types of
stuff. Everything in the body is one of
those four types of stuff. Connective
tissue, muscle tissue, epithelial tissue
or uh and nervous tissue. Okay. So the
middle part, the flesh robot's the key
to everything. And the key to the flesh
robot is the mus is the connective
tissue. If you want to picture what the
connective tissue looks like, how it's
related to the muscle tissue, think of a
cross-section of the flesh robot. Here's
the flesh robot. Cut a cross-section
out, pull it out. That's a stake. A
stake is the cow or whatever the animal
is. U a flesh robot slicing a
cross-section. And you can see the
connective tissue and the muscle tissue
interacting with each or in uh
integrated with each other in the steak,
right? have the marbling and the and the
the uh the pink part is the muscle
tissue. Most of us we most of the time
we eat the muscle tissue. As it turns
out, the connective tissue's got just as
much if not even more health benefits
than the muscle tissue for eating. And
that's the stuff we throw out. Now, if
you're a chef or a cook, you know that
the muscle tissue actually or the
connective tissue actually gives the
muscle tissue flavor because there's fat
and fat is a type of connective tissue,
by the way. And so that flesh robot is
the key to everything. And the key to
the flesh robot is the connective
tissue. Making sure you're
strengthening, building, and building
the connective tissue and and not doing
things that degrade the connective
tissue is the key to everything. Now,
when we talk about the connective
tissue, most of us we think of the
structure. And we just talked about how
the connective tissue also electrifies
and uh provides coherence. But the
connective tissue does something else.
And when I say connective tissue, I'm
talking about the collagen and the goo.
They're basically together. It's you
can't they're not really isolated in the
body. They're inter they're integrated
in the body.
The key to the uh possibly I don't want
to say the most important but one of the
most important things that the
connective tissue does is it feeds all
of the cells.
It functions like a womb.
In fact, the connective tissue is
sometimes called the connective tissue
matrix. Matrix means womb. So in
addition to electrifying and providing
structure, it also feeds, oxygenates and
um neut uh detoxifies uh all of the
cells just like a womb does for a fetus.
Womb functions in the same fashion as a
fetus. So you can think of the
connective tissue as a womb for all of
the cells because all disease is cell
disease. Once the connective tissue
doesn't do its work, you get sick
because all disease is cell disease and
the cells depend on the connective
tissue to be fed, to be oxygenated, to
be detoxified, and to be electrified. So
you can see that building the connective
tissue and collagen being the key
component of the connective tissue is
critical for cell health. It's critical
for structure of the body and it's
critical for electrification and
coherence. You can see there's a lot of
things that building connective tissue,
a lot of roles that connective tissue
plays and a lot of reasons why you want
to build connective tissue. By the way,
the blood is liquid connective tissue
and the vessels that um channel the
blood, those are connective tissue, too.
The heart sits on a framework of
connective tissue and once the
connective tissue deteriorates, the
heart doesn't function as effectively.
And it's very likely that one of the
underappreciated or even nonappreciated
causes of heart disease is connective
tissue deterioration. We focus on the
organ but we don't focus on the support
structures. And this is more of this
reductionistic mo uh reductionistic
perspective that the medical model takes
on health and healing and physiology and
aging and all the all the reasons we go
to the doctor. We focus on what we see,
but we don't focus on the support
support systems.
What we see, the heart or the spleen or
the intestine or the lungs, we're only
going to be as functional as as the
support systems are healthy. So, if you
have heart disease and you go to the
cardiologist and he focuses on the
heart, which is what doctors do, it may
be a good idea to focus on the
connective tissue that supports the
heart or any other organ. Follow what
I'm saying? Skin. Those of us in the
skin business know this well because
we've been it's been drilled into our
head the uh the relevance of connective
tissue. Although most people still think
of the connective tissue or the collagen
in in the skin as only being there for
the structure of the skin. But now we
know if you listen to what I just said
that the connective tissue in the skin
is going to help detoxify cells,
electrify cells, feed cells and uh and
oxygenate cells as well. So the collagen
in the skin is not just important for
keeping the structure of the skin
intact, but it's also important for the
health of all the skin cells.
You can see there's a lot of reasons why
you want to be building connective
tissue, i.e. collagen. Now before we get
into collagen specifically, there is the
goo. And while I'm isolating the two,
they're really not isolated. They're
integrated with each other. And as goes
the collagen, so goes the goo and vice
versa. Now, while collagen supplements,
which we're going to talk about here in
a second, are important, so are goo
supplements,
and you can use goo supplements like
fuccoidin and like hyaluronic acid as
nutritional supplements. And they do use
fuccoidin and hyaluronic acid as
nutritional supplements to help support
the goo. Now, importantly, when you take
these substances, it's not like you make
they go into your bloodstream and all of
a sudden you make your own um you make
your own goo out of the high aluronic
acid. These elements function more as
signaling molecules as does collagen.
I'll talk about that here in a sec with
collagen. What do I mean by signaling
molecules? The body is built, the way
the body is structured is it's looking
for damage.
It's always looking to help, it's always
looking to repair damage. What these
connective tissue building supplements
like high aluronic acid, like fucoidin,
like uh collagen, like um what are some
other some other connected tissue?
Glucosamine. What these glucosamine is
along the same lines. Glucosamine is is
one of those molecules that helps form
the goo.
They tell the body there's damage. I say
signaling when you eat these when you
take hyaluronic acid or glucosamine or
or collagen supplements, the body sees
pieces of collagen or pieces of
glucosamine or high aluronic acid
floating in the bloodstream that
shouldn't be there. So to the body, that
looks like there's damage.
You with me? It looks like there's been
a wound. So what is the body's response
to wounding? Growth.
So these elements signal and that's
their most important role. Now if they
get broken down enough there, you'll get
some of the building blocks, the amino
acids. Collagen is made up of three
amino acids. And so you'll get some of
those amino acids and they'll go into
the liver and they'll form a pool from
which you can draw on later. But for the
most part, the reason these connective
tissue building supplements are
important, whether it's collagen or whe
whether it's um uh the proteoglycans or
the or the polysaccharides that form the
goo, it's because they signal, they tell
the body it's time to grow. But that's
just one element of this this whole uh
collagen building and connective tissue
building chemistry. There's other things
that have to happen. For example, the
cells that make the collagen and the
connective tissue or and the the uh goo
are called fiberblasts.
The fiberblasts have to be healthy in
order to be able to secrete the
collagen. All diseases, cell disease,
remember? So, if the fiberblasts aren't
healthy because they're not getting
their mighty 90 essential nutrients, you
take all the collagen you want, it's the
fibiberblasts aren't going to be able to
build the connective tissue. They're not
going to be able to secrete the
connective tissue. It's about the cells.
The cells have to be healthy. So, it's
not just taking collagen. You still need
the mighty 90 essential nutrients to
make sure that the fiberblast the which
are actually going to be making the
collagen in response to the signals are
functional.
Another thing that has to happen if
you're going if you're going to be
effectively making collagen is you need
co-actors. Remember, the collagen you're
taking is not going to be your collagen.
The the the goo you're ingesting is not
going to become your goo. They're going
to signal. Does that make sense? You
follow what I'm saying? There's this
connotation that I eat collagen, it goes
into my blood and I get collagen. That's
not what happens. It's a signaling
effect. You understand what I'm saying?
That's why everything has to be
appropriate because you're just
signaling. If you don't have the raw
materials or the key materials, you're
not going to be able to make the
collagen just because you have the
signals. You can ring the doorbell all
you want, but if nobody's home, nobody's
answering the door. You follow what I'm
saying? So, so these are just signals.
Okay? So the collagen's important and
helpful as a signaling molecule, but you
still got to have the mighty 90
essential nutrients. In fact, one of the
mighty 90 essential nutrients is
considered to be the bottleneck or as we
say in chemistry, the rate limiting step
in the formation of collagen. The rate
limiting step is the step that has to
happen in order for everything else to
proceed. It's like a bottleneck. the
rate limiting step or the ingredient
this the nutrient that represents the
rate limiting step in collagen
production is what
>> you know
>> I'm going to say is it calcium
>> no you know
>> oh
>> vitamin C
>> well vitamin C yes
>> that's my that was my second guess
>> that was your second guess
>> the other C vitamin C is the rate
limiting step in collagen production
without vitamin C you ain't making
collagen in fact what's the disease
caused by vit Vitamin C deficiency.
Scurvy.
>> Barry. Berry.
>> No. Scurvy. Scurvy.
>> That's vitamin D.
>> Scurvy. Berry. Berry. As I can't AJ,
what's berry berry?
>> Diamond.
>> Damon. Vitamin B1.
>> Thamin.
>> Right. So, vitamin D would be
ricketetts. Vitamin D deficiency would
be ricketetts. So, in any case, um, uh,
vitamin C deficiency disease is called
scurvy. And that's when you don't make
any collagen. But here's what's really
interesting about vitamin C
deficiencies. It's on a spectrum. So if
you have no vitamin C, you're not making
any collagen. But if you have a little
vitamin C, you're going to make a little
collagen. So vitamin C supplementation
becomes critical. And in fact, in my
opinion, I haven't heard the people say
this before, but if you look at the
symptoms of scurvy, they align pretty
well with the symptoms of aging.
And it could very well be that aging is
a form of scurvy.
And that means that vitamin C could very
well be the anti-aging vitamin in
addition to all of the other things that
it's important for. And that's because
by virtue of its effects on the
connective tissue, the connective tissue
deteriorates, we fall apart and all of
the things we hate about aging really
about the connective tissue, i.e.
collagen and the uh and the goo.
So building connective tissue is
critical and building collagen is almost
synonymous although collagen is one one
component of the connective tissue. A
second co-actor that's important for the
production of collagen or for or for
effective collagen is sulfur. Sulfur
gives collagen a certain hardness
and collagen is or sulfur is what gives
collagen its strength and sulfur
deficiency is very common because sulfur
is found in soils and sulfur is leeched
out by acidity and over farming and so a
lot of us are deficient in this very
important element sulfur and you can
take all the collagen peptides you want
signaling but if you don't have the the
the sulfur you're not going to be able
to strengthen your collagen. So this is
all to say that when you're using your
collagen peptides, you want to think of
them as signaling, but you still need to
have all the raw materials to make the
collagen, i.e. the vitamin C and the
sulfur and the amino acids to make the
collagen. And then lastly, you got to
make sure that the the cells are
healthy. One of the most damaging things
to cells, as we all know, is sugar. And
sugar doesn't only damage cells, but
sugar also damages connective tissue via
process called glycation. Sugar reacts
with connective tissue and causes it to
burn. And in fact, if you're diabetic,
you'll have to go uh every six month,
every couple of months to get your
hemoglobin A1C te tested. And that's a
measurement of how fast you're sugaring
or caramelizing or or candying, if you
will, to glycating.
Hemoglobin is a protein and and sugar
glycates the hemoglobin and they measure
how how much of the hemoglobin is
glycating and by that they can tell how
well your blood sugar is being
controlled.
Cigarette smoke also has a damaging
effect on collagen. One of the other uh
underappreciated roles for collagen and
the connective tissue is the connective
tissue acts like a filter for the blood.
Now we always talk about all disease
cell disease but all cell disease is
preceded by dirty blood. One of the ways
that the blood cleans itself out is by
getting filtered through the connective
tissue. And then the connective tissue
is susceptible to toxicity and immune
attack. And this can result in
autoimmunity. And there are lots of uh
autoimmune diseases that affect the
connective tissue. The most the most um
well-known and maybe the most
problematic is rheumatoid arthritis.
And this is all caused by the filtering
effect of the connective tissue. And
this is something that medical folks
don't recognize.
medical folks still, the newer ones
still, the younger ones understand this,
but the older ones still don't say see
autoimmune disease as having a cause or
having a known cause. They'll tell you
there's no known cause for these
autoimmune diseases. Autoimmune
diseases, as I've said for years, and
you're going to find out more and more,
they're going to be recognizing this is
the end result of the same thing that
causes all other health challenges,
which is toxicity in the blood. In the
case of uh autoimmunity, the toxicity in
the blood gets dumped out into the soft
tissue or gets filtered out through the
connective tissue.
So building I hope I I made a very solid
case here for the importance of building
connective tissue and this is where we
come to our new longevity products the
collagen peptides or actually the
collagen peptides are not new uh the
collagen I think it's the boost it's the
shot that's new what do they call it
>> shot it's a new one there's more than
just the shot because there was two that
I forgot to add to your list
>> okay
>> where we have the Plus
>> Sax
>> super fruit.
>> Yeah, the Saxi super fruits juice mixed
with collagen.
>> Okay. That has collagen in it.
>> They Yep. They put a collagen in there.
>> Okay. All right.
>> And then also Fucoid Z. Now Fid Plus
comes with
>> collagen which is
>> what I have in here.
>> And that's a perfect blend.
>> That's a perfect to share it with you.
>> Okay. So, so let's talk about you want
to talk about the what's what's the new
collagen shot called? It's the name of
it.
>> It's called super collagen shots.
>> Okay. So, super collagen shots is a a
drink of collagen and collagen liqufied
makes it easier for the body to process
first of all and before you get into the
um the uh the shot. What did you call it
again? The s what was it called?
>> Super collagen shot.
>> Super collagen shot. Okay. Okay. Or the
collagen shot, we'll just call it. Um, I
should tell you that this is one of the
reason why bone broth is so important.
Bone broth and chicken soup are
basically liquid connective tissue.
You're drinking connective tissue. You
can actually see it. Connective tissue
or I said connective tissue organizes
liquid, organizes water. And when water
is organized, it forms a certain
structure. And you can actually see that
structure in your chicken soup or in
your bone broth. You can kind of see
that the it looks like water. The broth
looks like water but has a certain
bounce to it almost like a solidity to
it and that is a form of structure that
that's a a visible manifestation or
demonstration of the structuring of the
liquid by the collagen. So the collagen
shot is really interesting. First of all
it's liquid so it's easy for the body to
process. It's made up of um collagen
peptides. Now there's a some confusion
around collagen and collagen peptides.
Okay, first of all, collagen um doesn't
survive the digestive tract intact with
the exception of of collagen type two.
And let me digress real quick. There's
about 28 different types of collagen in
the body. And they're they're all
basically the same, but they're varied
by the proportions of the way the uh
amino acids are proportioned.
Specifically, actually the peptides are
proportioned. So, real quick quick
digression here. Um to simplify things,
think of collagen like a a long a chain
of beads, like a necklace, a bead
necklace. And then each bead represents
an amino acid. And then groups of amino
acids or groups of beads are called
peptides.
Most of the time when we when we get
collagen, we're getting collagen.
Peptides or sometimes you'll hear the
term hyd hydrayzeed collagen. Hydrayzeed
collagen describes what's happening to
the collagen to make peptides. So,
they're basically synonymous. Hydrayzeed
collagen and collagen peptides. They're
basically synonymous terms. There are um
28 different types of collagen and they
vary by the proportions of peptides and
and and amino acids, etc., but they're
all basically the same. Some have
different hydration properties,
different electrical properties,
different uh tensile strength
properties. You'll find some in the
eyes, some skin, some in the in various
tissues of the body. They're all
basically the same. If you're if you're
a physiologist, you might consider them
to be different, but they're all
basically the same from a nutritional
standpoint. When you eat the collagen,
if you eat intact collagen, it's not
going to make it past your digestive
tract with the exception of type two,
which does make it through the digestive
tract and gets into the lymphat area in
the intestine where your lymph is. None
of this getting into the bloodstream.
Collagen doesn't make it into the
bloodstream and that's a good thing
because it would initiate an immune
reaction. You don't want that. So
collagen functions as uh with the
exception of type two collagen it
doesn't get through the digestive tract.
Type two does get through the digestive
tract but even still they act as
signaling molecules to initiate the
production of your own collagen. And
that's really important to recognize.
Collagen signals. it doesn't it doesn't
act like a a source of collagen although
if it gets broken down enough the amino
acids can get um can get used as I said
earlier they they'll get stored in the
liver and the body can use them as a
pool so the most important uh collagen
types there's 28 of them but the most
important ones are going to be type one
collagen um that's going to be found in
your skin your tendons your joints your
ligaments and that's what that one is
very uh structured and organized and
In physiology, we call it the steel
cable. That's the one that acts like
steel. Type two collagen is also very
important. That's more like a shock
absorbing collagen. Um, and that one
resists compression. It doesn't really
have a stretching effect or as much of a
strengthening effect like the type one
collagen does, but it's um it's more
important for acting as a shock
absorber. And this is the one that is
the most well known for uh its hydration
properties. This is the one that's most
well known for having an ability to
organize and react with water. Uh, type
three collagen, not quite as important.
Type four collagen is a minor collagen.
The rest of them are are smaller
collagens. Type type uh type um four
collagen is kind of interesting. Type
four collagen is a civ. It acts like a
filter. That's one of the ones that we
talked about earlier that acts like a
filter for the blood. Uh, but the most
common ones are going to be type one and
type two. That being said, the collagen
shot, the liquid shot is made of
collagen peptides that are derived from
all the different forms of collagen. So,
you get not and not all of them. There's
19 of them. There's 28 different types
of collagen, but the one um the uh the
liquid collagen shot comes from 19
different types of collagen. Is that
right? I think it's 19, right?
>> Yeah. It's 19. So there's one, two,
three, four, five, six, seven, 9, 11,
12, 15, 16, 17, 18, 19, 22, 26, 27, and
28. Yes, I was paying attention, okay,
when it came to learning Roman numerals.
>> Okay, but those are those are the
collagen it's derived from. Once they
become collagen peptides, it doesn't
really matter where they're coming
coming from. The the types of collagen
are only relevant for the whole collagen
molecule. The peptides, whether it comes
from one or or or uh two or 19 or 18,
wherever it comes from, that's not
really that doesn't really have any as
much health relevance. What's really
relevant is the signaling effect of the
collagen peptides. Secondly, what's
relevant in the shot is the co-actors.
So, in um in the shots, you're going to
get vitamin C, right? You're also going
to get um and I correct me if I'm wrong,
but I think there might be whole Is
there whole collagen in there, too?
I don't know if there's whole collagen
in that
>> collagen blend.
>> Is there is the collagen blend is made
up of peptides, though, right?
I'm pretty sure the collagen blend is
peptides. Everything is
>> Yeah, it's all peptides. There's
bulbine.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah, it's all peptides though. It's
hydrayzeed and it's peptides. Uh, and
then there's also hyaluronic acid in the
formula. So, you're getting a
well-rounded connected tissue building
supplement with the collagen shots.
That's the bottom line. The collagen
shots also have uh if you use them with
your you do want to use them with your
meals, you'll get better absorption into
the intestine if you use them with your
meals. And I would throw in some fupoid
or some kind of sulfur amino acid, maybe
from eggs or from meat with them as
well. So, you make sure you get your
sulfur. You can also use your um your um
ultimate MSM to get sulfur or fucoidin
for that matter. There's fucoin fucoin
also has sulfur in it too. So it's good
idea to use sulfur and vitamin C and um
take your collagen shots with meals.
I think that's that's all I want to say
about I mean there's lots more I could
say about collagen. For folks in the
skin business, ingesting collagen on a
regular basis is one of the best things
you could do for your skin. in addition
to the topical strategies for building
collagen. And that's really interesting
because the skin is on the outside of
the body. We can drive collagen
synthesis by using things like peels,
retinol, topical vitamin C, laser
therapy. All of these wound healing
strate or wounding strategies stimulate
wound healing which drive the production
of of collagen. Also, exercise is
another great way to help drive the
production of collagen. And in fact, um
osteoporosis is really a collagen issue.
um as much as and vitamin C issue as
much as it's a calcium issue. Even
though calcium gets all the credit for
building strong bones, it's really a uh
osteoporosis is really a manifestation
of the degradation of collagen more than
it is a uh a calcium issue. And this is
why when people go to when astronauts go
to space, they have to exercise. they
could put them on an exercise bike or or
I don't know what kind of a rebound or
something to kind of exercise their legs
because they found that when people uh
when astronauts went to space they would
come back they would have very weak
bones they'd end up with osteoporosis
when they came back from from space so
now they make them exercise the exercise
drives the production of all the
connected of connective tissue uh uh
particularly connective tissue protein
which is collagen and there's by the way
there's also reticulin and elastin which
are minor proteins that are part of the
connective tissue system uh that are
made by fiberblast but collagen is the
main protein.
>> So just exercise here on earth whether
we're in space or not
>> exercise on earth is a absolutely it's a
must. It's a must. Yeah. And so for
people for women especially who are
worried about osteoporosis and on you
know these bonva drugs these they and by
the way the bisphosphinates these drugs
that call like bonva um fosmax there's a
few osteo there's a few other I forgot
the names of them but these drugs stop
the breakdown of bone they don't build
bone and stopping the breakdown of
collagen is a strategy that sometimes is
used in the skincare business and
sometimes you'll hear people say um uh
collagen ACE inhibitors.
Collagenase AS means an enzyme. Whenever
you hear ACE at the end of a word, it
refers to an enzyme. Collagen ACE
inhibition is a strategy strategy that's
used in skincare to keep collagen from
being broken down. But the you you want
collagen broken down because you want
new collagen. So the body is always
breaking down collagen and building it
up and breaking it down and building it
up. It assures fresh new healthy
collagen. Breakdown of collagen as I
said earlier is uh accelerated by poor
lifestyle habits especially smoking and
sugar which are two of the most
important ways that we break down our
collagen and it's one of two of the most
important u mechanisms for aging as
well. So, keeping your sugar down um and
uh uh keeping uh making sure that you're
not smoking cigarettes are two of the
most important things you could do to
keep your collagen intact. People don't
smoke cigarettes as much, but I still do
see people smoking. It's one of the
worst things you could do for your
connective tissue, for your body in
general.
>> I have a question in regards to sugar.
Does it is it matter if it's white sugar
or sugar and glucose fruit?
>> No, it doesn't matter. It's glucose and
fructose. Yeah, glucose and fructose
doesn't matter where it's where it comes
from. Although honey is a that's
probably the best sweetener there is
because it has co-actors in there that
help your body utilize use the sugar.
Um, but fructose has it has a a spectrum
of problems that are separate from
glucose. Fructose is especially
problematic for the liver. So fruit
sugar is not you got to be careful with
fruit sugar as much as you do with any
other kind of sugar. And the less sugar
we eat, the the better off we're going
to be. You do need to have a certain
amount of glucose obviously, but the
less we ingest, the better off we are.
>> Okay. Well, pharmacist Ben, you you're
sharing a lot of information. We have
people with questions. And of course, AJ
has the first question.
>> Yes.
>> AJ, go ahead and unmute yourself.
>> All right. pharmacist Ben, you know, um,
whenever you talk, I'm I'm I'm, you
know, I don't want to beat a dead horse,
but this is like amazing how our bodies
work.
>> It is. It is amazing. Yeah.
>> And it it's just it's kind of crazy. But
when you mentioned um
uh uh uh fiber uh blast fiber blast
>> fibroblast. Yeah.
>> Fibrolast. When you mentioned a
fibroblast,
I went to Dr. Google and say, "How do I
get more fibroblast?"
>> Well, you don't want you don't need more
fiberblast. You want healthy fiberblast.
It's not a question of number of fiber
blast. What did they say? What did Dr.
Google say?
>> Dr. Google says to increase fibroblast
production. You can use topical
treatments like retinoids and peptides.
Ingest collagen peptides or vitamin C or
get treatments like micro needling.
>> Yes.
>> Okay. But but that's like a that's like
a circle because I'm asking how do I get
something to help me build my collagen
and it's saying ingest collagen
>> because of the signaling.
Remember collagen acts like a signal
like a doorbell.
>> Okay?
>> You when you take collagen it rings the
doorbell basically that tells the
fibiberblast to make collagen.
So you're ingesting collagen to signal
to the fibiberblast to make your own
collagen.
>> Okay. But I'm asking how do I make
healthier fiberblasts?
>> All all the things and collagen.
>> No, no, no. Vitamin C and collagen are
important for turning the fiber blast
on. They're not for making this
fibroblast healthy.
>> Do you understand that distinction?
>> Do we need the 90 to make the fiber
blast?
>> Bingo. Bingo.
>> All right.
>> All disease is cell disease. And when I
say disease, they include aging.
Not really disease obviously, but
functionally that's what happens when we
age. Our bodies break down. So keeping
the cells healthy is the key to
everything. That's the first and
foremost. That's why things like
collagen peptides and growth factors and
other peptides, they're all and stem
cells, you know, sometimes now you're
hearing about stem cells and stem cell
condition media, all of that is
secondary. This is really important
because in the world of marketing and I
started off this talk by saying how
marketing and health are kind of
awkwardly related and sometimes the
interests of marketing are not
necessarily the interests of health. So
in the world of marketing we're always
looking for new and latest and the
greatest new ingredient and the newest
herb from the rainforest and the newest
formulation.
But in health it's all about the cells.
And the cells have been around for three
and a half billion years. And in that
three and a half billion years, they
have evolved a menu that they need in
order to be functional, in order to be
healthy, right? And that menu is fixed.
And there's no stem cells on the menu.
Collagen is not on the menu. And growth
factors are not on the menu. What's the
menu of a cell? What what is the menu
that provides the nutrients for a cell?
That provides the bu everything a cell
needs. the mighty 90 essential
nutrients. That's the menu. So, the
mighty 90 essential nutrients are the
primary for everything. That's why
they're so important. Nothing else will
make the cell healthy. The doorbell is
important. You got to ring the doorbell.
That's the signaling. You understand
what I'm saying? Doorbell. That's a
signaling molecule. But if your house is
burnt down or broken down, if it if it's
uh um you know, an abandoned home, you
can ring the doorbell all you want.
Nothing's going to happen. You got to
build the house first, then you put the
doorbell in. You build the house with
the mighty nine essential nutrients. The
fiberblasts are cells like any other
cells. They need vitamins, minerals,
amino acids, and fatty acids like any
other cell. And until you have all of
that, and most of us don't, you're not
going to be able to optimize or maximize
the effects that you get from the
signaling molecules. You follow? There's
the signaling molecules and then there's
the raw materials. What do you think's
more important?
>> Raw material.
>> Raw materials.
>> Okay. Pharmacist Ben. So, this this new
product's got 10 grams uh per shot of
this collagen blend.
>> Yes. And it's got um
uh some C in here. uh 30 milligrams and
at a hyaluronic acid it's got 10
milligrams. Now, how much collagen do I
need to be ingesting on a daily basis?
>> You don't need a lot because you're
signaling. Remember, this isn't going in
to make your body. This is just a
doorbell.
>> Okay. Okay. But
>> you only need only a small amount.
>> I cut my if I cut my arm
>> Yeah. I'm gonna have more
collagen in my blood signaling than,
>> you know, than if I'm just walking
around normally. Right. So,
>> right, you need you need to have some,
but it's not like you need the collagen
as a raw material for building collagen.
It's not like you need to have a a um a
depot of collagen to draw from to build
your collagen. You just need to signal
it and then your body will go into the
liver and pull out the glycine and the
and the proline and the veene and and
the vitamin C and it'll pull everything
together. All you're doing is signaling.
You don't need a lot to do that.
Milligrams is enough for signaling.
your body is made up, excuse me, you if
your if you weigh say 200 pounds and um
your protein is maybe let's say the
protein part of your body for argument
sake is 40% or so. So you have 80 pounds
of protein in a 200lb body and then 30%
of that is going to be collagen. You're
talking about, you know, 24 pounds of
this stuff. You don't necessarily need
that much collagen in order to build
your collagen. Why do I why do I
seemingly feel better if I take two
scoops of this?
>> Could be a lot of reasons. The peptides
could be turned into amino acids. You
may be using the amino acids. One of the
amino acids that makes collagen is
called glycine.
Glycine is arguably the most important
of all your amino acids. It's the
simplest amino acid. It's involved in
detoxification. It's involved in um uh
the health of uh of the liver. It's
involved in the building of connective
tissue. So you may be getting more
glycine. I don't know the answer to that
why you would feel better. But it's not
because of the signaling.
It could be the raw material. And
there's other things in that collagen
peptide formulation, isn't there?
>> It's not just collagen peptides.
>> There is. But I mean,
>> you're getting vit You're getting
vitamins in there, too. You're getting
vitamin Which one you talking about? I
think you're getting vitamin A. You're
probably getting vitamin C. You're
probably getting calcium, right?
>> No, not so much in this one. There's
more of this fulvic powder. So, I'm
guessing that's those are some minerals
in there.
>> The fulvic powder is amazing stuff.
>> Mhm.
>> Yeah, that's the fulvic powder. I use
them in skincare. They're amazing.
Bulvic powder is basically We talked
about this last week. I think it's the
stuff that is uh um the the the old
plants, the the I say old, I mean
millions, tens of millions of years old
plants that have been compressed into um
these these um mines that are located in
Utah and col and Colorado and New Mexico
that have all kinds of phytonutrients in
them and vitamins in addition to the
minerals and they're all water soluble
and they are electrified and they
improve coherence.
the coherence of liquid. They're
phenomenally important. And I didn't
mention that by the way. We talked about
coherence. Collagen is important for a
coherent water. Um the proteoglycans and
polysaccharides. The the goo is
important for cohering water. And the
minerals are important for a coherent
water. Those are the three most
important cohering elements uh
nutritional cohering elements that we
want to be using on a regular basis.
collagen, proteoglycans or um goo and uh
ionic minerals or fulvic minerals.
>> All right. Well, we have two more
questions before we end. So, Monnique
says, "I just ordered the collagen,
hair, skin, nails formula. How do the
enzymes like bromelene and papine
support collagen synthesis?"
>> They don't necessarily
Yeah, they don't they don't necessarily
support collagen synthesis, but they
help you absorb collagen. Collagen
being a protein, bromelain and papane
and um proteases in general help your
body absor uh they're enzymes that help
the body utilize the the proteins that
you eat, the collagen that you eat.
They're also anti-inflammatory. U
they're also improve blood uh blood
circulation. So there's a lot of
benefits to them. But anytime you ingest
protein, collagen being a protein,
proteasis will help your body process
them. Now, uh, proteasis and bromelain,
they may break down the collagen, uh, if
there, if you're taking whole collagen.
I'm not sure if there's whole collagen
or if it's just collagen peptides in
that product, but they may help you
break down the collagen into collagen
peptides. And I have to look at the
formula, but I think there's uh, and
correct me if I'm wrong, isn't there
fish collagen in there? Um, and, uh,
which is a whole form of
>> checking on
>> I'm pretty sure there's collagen on
that, but I think that there is. Yes,
>> I'm pretty sure there's whole collagen
in um in that formula. So, the enzymes
will support the breakdown of that
collagen into collagen peptides.
>> Hey, Ben.
>> Hey, Monique.
>> How's it going?
>> Good.
>> Good. This is great. This is such a
helpful information. I love this
breakdown. I mean, even for skin
especially because I'm constantly having
these conversations. But there's a
collagen blend. It has fish collagen and
then boine collagen. So, it's type one
and type two.
>> Are you talking about longevity product?
>> In the Youngevity collagen peptide,
hair, skin, and nail support.
>> Okay. So, they have fish collagen and
boine collagen.
>> Yes. And it looks like there's about
five grams.
>> Is it collagen or is it collagen
peptides?
>> It just says type one collagen.
>> Okay. So, if it's collagen,
>> then the bromelain and the papane are in
the formulation probably to break them
down into peptides. Got it.
>> Collagen is not going to make it into
with the exception of type two. That's
the one collagen that will make it into
the intestine. Most collagen is not
going to make it into your intestine
intact. It has to be broken down into
peptides. Of course, you need enzymes
and many of us don't make enough enzymes
or also another thing is acid. The
enzymes that help turn collagen into
collagen peptides
require low pH. So, if you're not making
enough stomach acid, and a lot of people
aren't, you're not going to be able to
activate the enzymes, and in turn,
you're not going to break down your
collagen into peptides. You're not going
to necessarily get the benefits. So,
while you're using your collagen,
peptides, hair, and skin, and nail
support, that's why I say take them with
food.
>> That will tend to improve the
acidification of um the stomach contents
and then improve the body's ability to
break that collagen down into collagen
peptides.
That's great. Thank you.
>> They are in peptide form, by the way.
>> They are already in peptide form.
>> Correct.
>> Okay.
>> Well, I know I do know that some of the
collagen in some of the products does
not say peptides following it. Um, but
my question, and we've got two more
questions after this, does it make a
difference if you mix these collagens
that are in powder form, you mix it with
water, does it make a difference if it's
cold water or hot water?
>> No. things will they'll dissolve better
in hot water. Um you don't want a
boiling hot water. You might denature
it. You might break them down. No, it
shouldn't matter. I would use warm water
or hot water if you want to use cold
water. They won't they won't dissol it
won't dissolve as effectively in cold
water.
>> Well, the one thing that I do love about
the collagen peptides is there's no
flavor to it.
>> I've had other collagens that one stink.
>> Yeah.
trying to drink it while you
>> you know what the stink is. You know
what the stink is, right? Sulfur.
It's collagen is in a lot of collagen
has sulfur in it. Collagen and sulfur go
together and that does have a stinky
kind of quality to it. I'm not sure why
these collagen peptides don't stink.
Maybe they don't have the sulfur in
there.
>> I'm just thankful. I'm thankful. Um so
let's go to the next question. and
Yasina,
go ahead and unmute yourself. What
question do you have for pharmacist Ben
today?
>> Thank you. Um I do have a question. I
started on the um um what is it called?
It's called the hard pack. Excuse me,
brain and hard pack. I'm on the second
bottle of the um Tangi Tangerine. Okay.
My question is I um I suffer from um
uh ringing in the ears, both ears,
buzzing, whooing, um lightadedness,
especially when I'm looking down. Um
Okay.
>> Um I work on I work on the computer all
day. So, I mean, I I have to take breaks
because otherwise I do feel laded.
>> Are you a coffee drinker? Are you a
coffee drinker?
>> No. No, I don't. I don't drink caffeine.
I don't smoke or drink. Um, I try to eat
clean homecooked meals. I do feel better
once I started on this me uh vitamins
and minerals. I do feel better,
>> but I'm not there yet. And I
>> give it some time, first of all. Second
of all, um, do you notice that when you
bend down to pick something up or touch
your toes or something and then stand
up, you get dizzy or woozy or the the
vertigo or
>> Yeah. Okay. So all of those are signs of
adrenal duress. Your adrenal glands are
your stress glands. They also make
female hormones particularly after
menopause. So if you're post-menopausal,
are you post post or perry?
>> Yes, I am. Yes. So that
>> I do have uh the symptoms of that as
well.
>> Yeah. So what you want to do is you want
to be supporting your adrenal glands.
Now you can't necessarily support the
adrenal glands directly, although
there's a few things you could do and
I'll tell you about that in a second.
But the most important things you can do
for the adrenal glands is keep your
blood sugar stable and um support
digestive health and oxygenate.
And in fact, you may notice that if you
um
practice slow and it's very important
that it's slow, deep, by deep, I mean
diaphragmatic where you activate the
diaphragm breathing before you stand up
from a seated position or u before you
move move your posture, change your
posture that you don't have that or it's
significantly less dizziness or
wooziness. So you might want to try
that. Okay. oxygenation. And then there
are things that you could do directly
for the adrenal glands. Um, and a couple
of them include vitamin C, the B
complex,
particularly vitamin B5
and iodine. Those are all
>> Is that in the pack? Is that in the pack
that I'm taking?
>> You probably want to take extra on
those. They're not necessarily designed
for folks who have adrenal issues.
Another issue with the adrenal glands
and what this what you're experiencing
is something called postural
hypotension.
And that's where your blood pressure
drops when you change posture. See, when
you change posture from even just
turning your head or standing up,
bending down, those are all postural
changes. There's an incredible amount of
complex chemistry that happens to change
the way blood flows through your body.
Do you understand what I'm saying? I
mean,
>> yes.
the the way blood is shunted through the
body involves a whole bunch I mean not I
say a whole bunch but really an infinite
amount of opening and closing can you
imagine all the opening and closings
that have to happen in order for blood
to get directed the right way that's all
controlled by the adrenal glands when
your adren and to a certain extent the
kidneys when the and by the way adrenal
means on top of the kidneys there's a
there's a connection between the renal
system and the adrenal system they both
are very important for blood they're
probably the two most important systems
for blood pressure control. And so when
your blood pressure is not being
controlled properly,
when you change posture,
you're going to experience the effects
of blood that's not being shunted
correctly. And one of the signs is
dizziness or wooziness.
Make sense? You follow me? So it sounds
to me like a combination of a
circulatory problem and a and a a
adrenal problem. Now, post-menopause,
the adrenal glands are going to um bear
a lot of the burden for steroid hormone
synthesis because now you're not making
them in your female reproductive system.
You're making them in the adrenal
glands. So, that puts an added stress on
the adrenal system. So, it becomes
really really important post-menopause
or or pmenopause that you focus on
adrenal health. And as I say, blood
sugar and digestion are two of the most
probably the two most important things
you could do for the adrenal glands.
Oxygenation is very important for the
adrenal glands. There are nutrients that
are important for the adrenal glands.
And then lastly, but maybe as important
as everything else is the adrenal glands
are your stress glands. And there's a
very important relationship between
mental stress, psychological stress, and
physiologic stress. The adrenal glands
are going to respond to uh mental and
emotional stress the same way they'll
respond to physiologic stress. So to
your adrenal glands, it doesn't matter
if your stress is, you know, bills or
your family or your job or whatever it
is as opposed to a real lion or tiger or
bear. So working on psychological and
emotional stresses as well as
physiologic stresses is also important
for adrenal health. And the fastest way
to hack into adrenal health or or stress
management is oxygenation.
>> Okay. And that was the breathing method,
correct? Breathing.
>> Yes. Before Yeah. Try an experiment the
next time you um you know experience
postural hypotension that is and and
this dizziness is a hypotension
phenomena. It's a low blood pressure
phenomena. So the next time that happens
try practicing some breathing techniques
and then move and see if you notice a
difference.
>> I also take uh 50 milligrams of loartin
the
>> well that yeah that's that's not going
to you know that's not going to help
you. That's not going to help the
adrenal system loartin. Okay. Um but you
know that's between you and your doctor.
What did you have a diagnosis a heart
disease diagnosis or blood pressure?
>> No it it all started when I uh started
having menopausal symptoms. It all
started the anxiety the um blood
pressure going up. Um
>> that could be that that could be because
of the adrenal issues. Like I say
postmenopause or pmenopause during
menopause your adrenal glands are going
to start working harder. So, if you're
already have some adrenal issues and now
you're going to menopause, that could
put a burden on the an excess burden on
the adrenal system.
>> Is there something any supplements that
I can take to support my adrenal uh
glands?
>> Um, there's not I don't have any single
supplements. I think we have a d we have
a product called d-stress. Um, but
>> yeah, we have dstress and we also have
adrenal support in the good herbs line.
>> Yeah, you might want to use those. The
most important nutrients as I said are
the B complex particularly vitamin B5
vitamin C and iodine. Uh and then you
can also use the D-stress or the adrenal
support supplement I think. Is that the
stay natural? Is that Laura Dennison's
product?
>> Um no the the adrenal support is in the
good herbs tincture line.
>> Okay. Yeah. Those are two adrenal
supplements, but the B complex,
especially B5, iodine, and vitamin C are
the three most important adrenal direct
adrenal nutrients. But it's really hard
to work on the adrenal glands directly,
aside from using those supplements,
which are not just only for the
adrenals. They're important for
everything. Um, but you can work on the
adrenal glands by working on the blood
sugar system and the digestive system.
And I don't know if you if you're new or
not, uh, but we talk about something we
call the triangle of disease. and the
triangle of disease are the three points
of bodily breakdown that underly
everything else. And those three points
are the digestive system, the blood
sugar system, and the adrenal thyroid
complex. And you haven't mentioned this,
but there's a very good chance that your
hypothyroid as well with all the stuff
that's going on with your adrenal
glands.
>> Thank you for the information.
>> Thank you, Sinia. Thank you.
>> Yes. And everybody, you can go to
triangleofdase.com
and find more information out about the
whole three points when it comes to the
triangle of disease. So, thank you so
much for that, Pharmacist Ben. And as we
have the co-host come on the screen with
us today. One final question and it's
coming from Barbara. She says, "So, it
seems it doesn't do any good to take
extra collagen peptides. Is that
correct? And this is a
>> What do you mean by extra? What is I
don't know what extra means.
>> Well, I'm putting collagen peptides in
my coffee. So, I loved the collagen in
there. I'm putting it I'm drinking it
with my fucoid Z. Um, just adding extra
things.
>> I would say more rather I don't know
what you mean by extra, but I would take
more rather than less if I had a choice,
you know. But I don't know what extra
mean. Yeah. I don't know what Exactly.
What qualifies as extra, but as an
insurance policy, it's better to have
more than less.
>> Got it.
Good. I love taking more. So, it all
tastes great and I feel good taking it.
And AJ, do you have one more question?
>> I kind of I kind of think you short
changed your sen a bit.
>> How so?
>> Cuz you didn't really tell her that
she's got a leaky gut and dirty butt.
>> Well, I you know, I say it all the time.
I might get sick of saying the same
thing, but yes.
>> Yeah, but she she's clearly a newer
person.
>> All right. Yes. Leaky gut. Well, you
should say it. You know, leaky gut and
dirty blood. Yeah. So, you know, I I
know we say it all the time. It always
feels Sometimes I feel
>> she can call us, but I mean, she's got a
>> The whole blood thing is very important
because
all disease is cell disease and all cell
disease begins with dirty blood. So,
cleaning the blood is very important.
That's where glycation and sugar come
in. Sugar is a a blood toxin, so to
speak. You need some. It's hard to say
it's a toxin because you need some, but
it can have negative effects. It can
thicken the blood. It can be
inflammatory for the blood. And of
course, toxicity that enters in through
a leaky gut can also be uh creates
thickening of the blood. So, it's this
hypercoagable blood that impedes
circulation that is behind all of these
health challenges. And yes, you're
right. I didn't go into the details of
it, but it is a it is a leaky gut and
gly and sugar phenomena. Yes, that's
true.
You mean to embarrass me? Is that what
you're talking about? Is that
>> I hope you're not embarrassed because
because I actually have some pictures I
drummed up.
>> Okay. Do you have them? Do you have them
up now?
>> No, I don't. I don't.
>> Okay.
What about Monday when we talk Monday?
>> We do on Monday. You look real muscular
in one of them.
>> I do.
>> Did you Is it AI AI muscles?
>> We'll find out Monday. Well, we on nine
or 10 on Monday, do you know?
>> Uh, nine.
>> Okay.
>> Okay. All right, everybody. Thank you,
Monique. I'll see you in a half an hour.
>> All right. Well, do. Thank you.
>> Okay. Bye, everybody.
>> Thank you. Thank you. Thank you,
everybody,
um, for being here with us on Daily with
Doc and Becca. And especially thank you
to pharmacist Ben Fuches for taking time
out of his busy schedule. And I am super
thankful for my co-hosts as they take
time from their families and their
schedules to help us put this program
together for you.
So, thank you so much, AJ. Excuse me.
Thank you, AJ, for um helping us get all
the stream set up and ready to go.
Albert, thank you for letting people in.
monitoring the chat. Just greatly
appreciate each and every one of you as
we are working on a skeleton crew today.
And Monnique, thank you so much for
being part of our co-host team as well.
Folks, if somebody referred you to this
program, they are your number one
contact. Get back with them if you have
any questions or want to get any of the
products that are mentioned on this
program. Chances are they are part of
the Youngevity family as a distributor
or a health coach or even a certified
holistic health coach and they cared
enough about you to share this program
with you. So, show them gratitude. I
think 2026 would be a year of gratitude
all the way around where we need to not
overlook the power of saying thank you
and getting back with people and even
showing our gratitude towards people and
more than just words when they have
helped us by taking time because time is
money. But anyways, thank you so much
everybody. I am really looking forward
to 2026.
We're also going to be having some
guests that we have not had on the show
before and also some ones that we had
last year becoming more regular which
I'm super excited about. You know,
this program is a resource for an
amazing community and I just want to do
a shout out to that community as you are
taking time to learn more about how the
body works and also what we can do
nutritionally to support the body. So
if you have any even a little bit of
interest in helping yourself, your
family, your community, there is a place
for you in this family. Again, get back
with a person that shared this program
with you. And if there's no one to
thank, you found us on your own, you're
not already involved in the Youngevity
family and taking products or working
with somebody, we do have a call team
standing by at 855-9493377.
Again, 855-9493377.
This program is sponsored by
dailywithdoc.com where you can find more
information including links to our
previous programming. And don't forget
to sign up for our newsletter so you
don't miss a show and you can get more
information delivered right to your
inbox. So until next time, my name is
Becca Dukes and as a certified holistic
health coach, certified naturopathic
practitioner and also the director of
students student services for the
Institute of Holistic Health. Have a
fantastic day. And if you're want more
information about becoming a certified
holistic health coach, go to
coach.dwithdoc.com.
Again, that's coach.dwithdoc.
dailywithdoc.com.
Until next time, bye for now.
This program is for educational purposes
only. The content is not intended to
[music] diagnose, treat, cure, or
prevent any diseases, nor is it intended
to take the place of your primary care
physician. Statements in [music] this
program have not been evaluated by the
FDA. As an empowered individual, you do
have options available. We're honored to
continue and share the teachings of the
founding father of science of
epigenetics, Dr. Dr. Joel Wallock.
This program is for educational purposes
only. The content is not intended to
diagnose, [music] treat, cure, or
prevent any diseases, nor is it intended
to take the place of your primary care
physician. [music]
Statements in this program have not been
evaluated by the FDA. As an empowered
individual, you do have options
available. are honored to continue and
share the teachings of the founding
father of science of epigenetics, Dr.
Joel Wallik.
This program is for educational purposes
only. The content is not intended to
[music] diagnose, treat, cure, or
prevent any diseases, nor is it intended
to take the place of your primary care
physician. Statements [music] in this
program have not been evaluated by the
FDA. As an empowered individual, you do
have options available. who are honored
to continue and share the teachings of
the founding father of science of
epigenetics, Dr. Joel Wallik.